- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the "Daily Homeroom."
It's been a little bit of a while.
We took a week long break last week,
so hopefully everyone is doing well.
For those of y'all who are new to this.
This is something that we started doing
when we started seeing
the school closures,
but it's really a way
for all of us to connect
and talk about topics
that are both interesting
and educational, not just in education,
but beyond education.
And we have a really exciting guest
from our Khan Academy Team today
and where we have an exciting
set of announcements there.
But before I get into that,
I do like to remind folks
that Khan Academy is a not for profit,
that we exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And so if you're in a position to donate,
please think about doing so
and a special thanks
to several corporations
that have stepped up over
the last several months,
especially once we started having
the increased costs due to COVID.
We were already running at a deficit
before COVID and now our deficit has grown
but special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
Their help has made a huge difference,
but we're still running at a deficit.
So anything that folks can do to help
would make a big difference.
With that I'm really excited to introduce
a colleague of mine here at
Khan Academy Lindsay Spears,
who's a senior math content manager,
Lindsay, good to see you.
We see each other.
- Thanks (mumbles)
- This days its on Zoom a lot.
So tell us a little bit about
and this is a reminder
for everyone watching,
if you're on YouTube or
Facebook put questions,
we have folks who are looking at it
and they'll surface it
to myself and Lindsay.
But Lindsay tell us the announcement
that we have made recently.
- Yeah, so really exciting.
We've built 10 new courses in math courses
that are kinda get ready
for grade level courses.
They start with third grade,
get ready for third grade
and go all the way to
get ready for precalculus
and they're built to help students
who are going into that upcoming course
prepare for that, the course
that they're headed into
the math course they're headed into.
- And why did we do this?
- Yeah, we did this because we know
every year there's a summer slide, right?
Students lose a little bit
of what they've learned
in the last year, over the summer.
But this year with the
school closures due to COVID,
we knew that was gonna be
even greater than normal
and we wanted to find a
way to help address that.
And so the courses are
really to help students,
let's say, going into fifth grade
with here we know this is the content
you're about to take on in fifth grade
and the topics you're gonna explore
and to have a really successful
year with those topics.
Here's some skills that we think
would really help you
prepare and help you be ready
to take on those next topics.
So we built a smaller courses
that really get you ready
for what you're about
to learn in the Fall.
- Yeah, this notion, this is
this isn't a covert thing.
This is even pre-COVID kids you
know we talk a lot about it.
As they're moved through
kind of a fixed pay system,
they inevitably accumulate gaps.
And then you have things
like Summer Vacation
where not only do you, not,
not only do you not learn,
but you often forget,
and some of and the skills
that you did know, atrophy,
and then those gaps that
you have continued to exist,
or maybe even get bigger.
That's always an issue,
which is why we've always talked about
the value of personalized learning,
being able to learn at
your own time and pace.
But this year, to your point,
it's likely to be that much worse
because some students have
been able to keep learning
on say Khan Academy while others haven't.
And so these get ready
for grade level courses
are way for students, parents,
or teachers working with those students
to make sure they have all
of the prerequisite skills
up to and including the grade level,
up to the grade level work
and then they can of course work on
at their own time in place.
And I mean, this sounds,
we had Tim Vandenberg
on, I guess we call it the
show, we had him on this show.
It seems like a lifetime ago,
I think it was about two months ago now.
And, you know he did
something similar with kind of
Khan Academy before the
get ready for grade level.
He had all of his sixth graders,
90% of whom were at a below grade level
when they entered into his classroom,
he had them all started early learning,
kindergarten level math,
and then go through all of
arithmetic on Khan Academy,
which has a lot of skills.
And he's seen really incredible
gains with those students.
They were not only able to
catch up to sixth grade,
they were able to learn sixth grade.
And many of them ended
up ahead of grade level.
How is this different than what kid
than what Tim Vandenberg does
or has been doing with his students?
- Yeah, what Tim does is so exciting,
starting all the way back in
kindergarten and going through,
what's slightly different
about these courses,
they're more focused
just on the one course
you're about to go into.
So they're really, we
really thought about,
you know, what does a seventh
grade math student take on?
What are the topics of seventh
grade math student learns
and built like a really
custom set of content
and exercises and videos
that support that very specific grade.
So they fill the gaps just like Tim does,
but they're filling a very personalized
or like the individualized set of gaps
that we know for that course.
So it's sort of like a
fast tracked Tim Model.
- Yeah, so far what's going on here
is essentially we want all
teachers to be able to do,
all students to be able to do
exactly what the students in
Tim Vandenberg class does.
But Tim Vandenberg was kind
of using existing things
on Khan Academy and his students
who maybe have to cover,
you know third grade
or fourth grade skills
that don't directly feed
into the sixth grade.
And so what we've essentially done
is taken Tim Vandenberg's intent,
but we've streamlined it,
so that teachers and students
have a much better chance
of getting to grade level
as quickly as possible.
And how, how would you
recommend teachers do use it?
Would you say that they should
have all their students work on it
for say the first, well they
could use it over the summer.
They could use it for
the first several weeks
of the school year, or should they go,
do the the unit in the
Get Ready For Grade Level
before they do the corresponding unit
in the grade level course.
- Yeah, I think there's a lot of
a couple of different
models that would work well.
Currently since we're
in the summer doing it,
doing the full course in the
summer is a great way to build,
know that if you have you know,
some time to spend on math this summer,
these are the best things
to use that time on.
And you could, could
do the complete course
over the summer ahead of time.
For teachers during the school year.
I think there's a lot of
value in doing it in line.
And so the way we've built the course is
each of the units will say,
like in sixth grade, get ready for ratios
because we know all sixth
graders are gonna spend
a lot of their year learning ratios.
So as the teachers
preparing to teach ratios
to start that unit, she or he can use
the Get Ready For Ratios unit.
You could even use them at the same time.
You could you know,
simultaneously be working
on sixth grade ratios
while also building
those strong foundations
to support that learning.
Or you could do it one after the other.
So I think there's a model
where you could do the
whole thing upfront,
but really for teachers
and during the school year,
I think there's an enormous
advantage to doing it during,
so that you're filling the gaps
right at the time those
gaps are needing filling
and really getting to
build the connections
between what you've
learned in earlier years
and what you're learning this year.
- And to your point,
the units in the Get Ready
For Grade Level Course,
they're actually named, so
that they line up nicely
with units in the Grade Level Course.
So your point about ratios,
which is a sixth grade,
there's a unit in the sixth
grade course about ratios.
There's a unit in the Get
Ready For Six Grade course,
called getting ready for ratios,
- Right, yeah, they pretty much parallel.
There's a few units that maybe
it's brand new to that year
so there may not be a get ready unit,
but in general, you should
be able to do a crosswalk
between the Get Ready course
and the On-grade course,
and they should match up pretty neatly.
- And what's your, what would you say?
You know a lot of teachers
like, well this sounds great.
'Cause every teacher we talked to knows
that kids come after a normal Summer
with all sorts of gaps
and this year is gonna be that much worse
as we were talking about.
But the teacher's like, you
know I already have trouble
covering all of the grade level material.
Now there's this whole other
course that seems ginormous
'cause it's covering so much material.
How do I do both?
Is this, what's the size of this course
relative to the normal grade level course.
- So the size of these courses
are somewhere between like
a 1/3 to 1/2 of the size
of the regular course.
So they're actually quite streamlined
and smaller than the On-grade courses
and it is additional content.
And I certainly remember that well
from my time in the classroom.
But we also I think sometimes
when you're filling the right gaps,
that it actually accelerates
the On-grade learning too.
So it might be additional,
but it's the right additional
that may make teaching the On-grade stuff
go even more smoothly.
- Right and we're seeing a screenshot
looks like this is our sixth grade core,
so there'd be a corresponding
get ready for sixth grade course.
- Sure so I can.
I can do.
- And to your.
- Go ahead Sal (laughing)
- Oh no, no, no.
I was saying to your point,
these are shorter courses.
And another element here is,
students in theory, if
they're ready for grade level
should know a lot of this material.
So they could probably use
our acceleration mechanics.
Things like course challenges, unit tests,
mastery challenges, quizzes to accelerate
through a lot of the material pretty fast.
That's exactly right,
and on this, I can show you.
So this is our main ongrade sixth grade,
but just to show how to get to the courses
anywhere that we are, you
are on Khan Academy up here.
If you click on the courses,
the get ready courses
are listed right here.
So we have our main math courses below it,
but right here, we have
the get ready for third,
fourth, fifth, sixth.
So if we click into,
or we can go to the main, get ready page,
and this has all of the
different get ready courses.
And if we click into one
and just begin this first one here,
we can see it's a bit
smaller than the main ones.
This has 37 exercises
to try as opposed to,
the main third grade course,
which has over a hundred different skills
that you would do in the on-grade course.
And what do you recommend,
you know speaking of acceleration,
let's say you do it in line,
so that you do the Get Ready For unit
right before, or at the same time
as the corresponding unit at grade level,
would you recommend,
teachers maybe leverage
like the unit test?
I'm making stuff up,
you know the kids take the unit test
if they're doing well on it.
If they get you know 90 plus percent,
maybe they don't even
necessarily have to finish
the Get Ready For Grade Level,
but they could probably
finish it quite quickly.
But if they get a lower
score on the unit tests,
then that little students
should be able to go
to the what they had gaps in.
- Yeah, that's right
so they can accelerate
in a few ways.
You could take the course challenge,
which would show you a variety of skills
from the entire Get Ready course.
Or if you really wanted to focus on
a really one you know to see,
are they ready for place value?
Is my class ready?
So if you went to the get
ready for place value unit,
and just did that unit test,
it's gonna show you either
some students they're ready.
They really have all
those foundational skills
and they're ready for on grade.
And if not, it'll help you identify
it'll show the different skills
where they were not yet successful,
and it will help that students say,
"okay, here's a few things in place value
"that I need to go back to
and get some practice in."
So it will help them
identify help the teachers
and the students identify
if they're already you know ready
for the grade level content,
or if there's a little bit more work
they could do to prepare.
- And there's a bunch
of questions coming in.
So from Facebook, Robin Schwartz asks,
"what would you recommend for
raising a college freshmen
"who will be,
"who will be in a summer
academic skills course?"
Is there a way to take,
to take off the grade level,
get ready for algebr one looks great.
I have, I think I think what the question
what's Robin's asking is
am at maybe asking about a family member
or maybe Robin is in college,
but you know if someone's
gonna be a rising freshmen,
depending on what the
rising freshmen is taking,
some freshmen will take kind of a,
a college algebra course,
some of them will take a
precalculus or calculus course,
do they have get ready for
grade level courses there?
- We don't have get Get
Ready For Grade Level
specifically for the college courses,
but I think the college level algebra,
if you are gonna do get
ready for algebra one,
or get ready for algebra two,
the combination of those would
probably be a great support
for starting a lot of college
algebra level math courses.
And they're just really
gonna build that foundational
algebra content, the base of
all algebra understanding.
So really beneficial to pretty
much any college course,
if you wanted to get some practice in,
I think that would be
a great place to start.
- Yeah I mean, to your
point, college algebra,
you know the course college algebra,
is usually someplace,
it's usually pretty
analogous to algebra two
and a lot of places,
sometimes even a combination
of algebra one and algebra two.
So if you're getting
ready for those courses,
you are likely to be getting ready for,
and what are the most
advanced to get ready?
So the get ready courses start
at third grade or second grade?
- Starts at third grade,
but that coursework
- Starts at third grade.
- Full of second grade content,
and first, you know
some first grade content
and then it goes all the way
to get ready for pre-calculus
is the highest that it goes up to.
And that course is an
include a lot of content
from algebra one and algebra two
and even a little bit of geometry.
- Yeah, and so, you know going back to the
to the question is that,
you know as a lot of students
will take a precalculus course
and the precalculus college course
pretty much is the precalculus
high school course.
And so that would be a valuable
thing too for them to take.
- Yeah
- So let's see there.
So we already actually,
Cindy Wright from Facebook
asked the question that we just answered,
which is what grade levels do
the get ready courses cover?
And she says, we love Khan Academy.
- Yes.
- Cindy we love you too.
Let's see, we have from Facebook,
Amy Thompson Thompson
is this math specific,
anything for English language arts.
- These get ready courses
are math specific,
but we are also building
our main ELA content.
And so there is ELA content,
even including now elementary
and middle school on the site.
So there is great content for ELA practice
which would help you get
ready for the school year,
but they're not specifically
get ready for grade level
courses like we have right now.
- Right, and this is something
that we've talked a lot about
inside the organization,
which is math and ELA are different.
They have some similarities,
but there's different in
many ways, which is in math.
You definitely have these skills
that very clearly get built on
and are prerequisites for
each other while in ELA,
there's kind of your background knowledge,
there's your, you know you kind of
your Lexile level that you can read at.
And you can, you can
sometimes grok something
or understand something.
I use these science fiction
terms that I shouldn't,
(laughing)
you grok something from
stranger to strange land
to understand something deeply.
Grok something at a higher reading level
that it has some background knowledge
that you might not fully have.
You can still sometimes
engage in a text like that
while in math if you're
looking at an equation
that has a negative exponent in it,
and you don't understand
negative exponents,
you're just gonna be kinda,
you're not gonna really have a shot.
So that's why he's getting
ready for grade level courses
are so relevant in math, especially
- Absolutely the way the
skills and math spiral
throughout the years, yeah really valuable
to have those foundational skills.
- Yup, so let's see
there's more a question.
So actually another question from Robin,
thanks this will be for an online class.
Do all students get the same exercises?
Lindsey, I could take a stab at it,
but I think I have an answer to but.
- I think the exercises are the same
in each get ready for grade level,
but each student won't see the same items.
So there's if two students are practicing
and get ready for ratios,
they're both gonna see the same skills,
but they might see different
specific questions,
not yourself, that's how you're,
you're also thinking of the question.
- Well, that's exactly right.
You know internally when
we talk about exercises,
we're talking about kind
of have a bucket of items
that are all addressing the same standard
or addressing the same skill.
And so, and one of the things
that a lot of folks don't realize that,
there's, there's like tools out there
that you know will give you some practice,
but they're essentially,
you know five questions
that everyone sees.
And if you tell your neighbor
the answer to question number two is C,
then they know the answer is C.
We spend a lot of time and resources
and Lindsay's Team especially
we make far more items
than the student is likely to see
so that they can get as much practice
as they need in those skills.
And to Lindsay's point,
students that are next
to each other, there'll be
working on the same standards.
They'll be working on the same skills.
Not necessarily they could
go from beginning to end
and do it in the same order.
But very often when they
do the mastery challenges,
there'll be different, even
skills that are being covered
that are more relevant
to what that student needs to work on.
And when they work on a given skill,
the problems they see are very
are likely to be very,
are likely to be different
than what their classmates sees.
But as a teacher, you get a skills report.
And then if you do
things like assignments,
you can actually understand which items
gave your students the
most difficult demo,
which individual questions,
which which can also be really useful.
So let's see.
- Similarly, I might add
that the student was gonna,
if you're thinking about doing
this in the Summer versus
the School Year,
if you did these in the Summer,
you would likely see different items
that you saw in the school
year, even the same student.
So you would be able to
use this multiple times
and still see a variety of items,
even for one single student.
- Yup, Now let's see from from YouTube,
Simone Cruz asks, do
you offer certificates
that would help motivate the children
after they complete the course?
I don't know if we have
certificates, but I do know
that we're running a
Camp Khan this summer,
which is a program that's
gonna have different incentives
and weekly learning objectives
built around these, get ready
for grade level courses.
It starts today, actually launched today,
but you can join any time between now
and I believe it ends August 28th
and there's a webinar
later in the week on Thursday about that.
But so there is a campaign around it
that I believe will have
some different incentives
as students work though it.
- Yeah, exactly you know Camp Khan
is it you know the get ready
for grade level courses
got launched at the end of
last week, they're all live,
everyone can do it.
And then Camp Khan is really a way,
ideally if every child in
the country or the planet,
or I guess the universe were
to start learning the Summer,
then everyone would be
ready for grade level.
And frankly they could finish the course
and then start on their grade level course
before they even get back to school.
And Camp Khan to your point
and I'm very self-conscious about
we overuse this for the whole Khan thing
but (all laughing)
the but Camp Khan is about that exactly.
It's about motivating
students and families
to engage over the summer to learn.
And it is focused on to get
ready for grade level courses,
which you and your team have,
have really done an amazing
job putting together.
It's useful outside of
this COVID strangeness
that we're dealing with
but it's especially useful right now
when there's gonna be a huge
variance in students' learning.
So let's see Andres Torres
from Andre Torres from YouTube.
Would we, would we see in the
future getting ready courses
for college level classes?
I could take a stab at it.
I mean, I think if,
- Sure.
- If this is well received, yeah,
we would seriously think about it.
You know obvious calculus, stats,
even a lot of the science
courses, one could imagine
A get ready for a course
could be a really,
really, really valuable,
I don't have anything
to add to that, Lindsay.
- Yeah, completely
agreed yeah, absolutely.
- Let's see from
Facebook, Mike Richie says
"I had my son take the fourth
grade curriculum challenge
"of the course challenge on your site.
"And he scored a 97%
"it then had him answer
six mastery questions,
"which he got right.
"Is it safe to say that I can move him on
"to the fifth grade curriculum?"
- I feel very comfortable
if that's how well he did
on the course challenge,
I think he's probably ready
to get fifth grade to try
and you know nothing is forever
if he moves on to fifth grade
and that's a real struggle.
Fourth grade is still there for him you
know we're always what we've
mastered and not changes
all the time, we don't
stay at a constant state
of what we remember.
So he could always go back
and revisit fourth grade,
but I would feel very comfortable
recommending he take, check
out the fifth grade content.
- Yeah and I completely agree with that.
And Mike, if your child
is doing that well in the fourth grade,
I actually think I'd be intrigued.
You could even start
the fifth grade course challenge as well.
I wouldn't be surprised if
they do quite well on that.
And then that can help
your child accelerate
to the skills in fifth grade
that they might actually,
that they need to focus on
that they haven't learned yet.
While some of it either
they might already know,
or they might be able to Intuit,
you know they already
know how to do you know
three digit multiplication
and, I don't think those are,
those might be, you know
the standards better
than I do Lindsay,
but, you know in theory,
some of the things you
might be able to Intuit.
So yeah, but your son or daughter
I think is very, very ready.
So let's see from Facebook, Matthew Tyler,
we have used Khan Academy for years.
We were grateful that you are
still innovating great work.
Well, Matthew I will say,
I mean, one of the fun things
about having Lindsay here
is I get a disproportionate
amount of the credit,
but it's great to see, you now,
now you know the people other than Sal
of which most of Khan Academy is
(laughing)
we're over 200 folks
who are doing a lot of the heavy lifting,
most of the heavy lifting for
making all of this possible.
So yes
- And that extend
(mumbles) me as well.
- That's for you thank you.
- So let's see other questions here
for those of you who
don't know what I'm doing.
I have this little Google
Doc below the window
where I see Lindsay, where I'm seeing,
so Sophia Patel says,
how do I join Camp Khan?
And our team put a URL here.
Philippe might be able to get
it up on the on the screen,
but it's khan.co.
Let's see, is it up on the
screen Camp Khan overview?
Well, it's khan.co/campkhan2020.
And I don't think capitalization matters,
but at least on the URL,
I'm seeing the C and Camp is capitalized
and the K in Khan is capitalized
khan.co/CampKhan2020
And hopefully if you
do a web search for it,
you'll be able to, you'll
be able to find it.
Oh, and I've given the note,
capitalization does matter.
So khan.co/CampKhan2020.
So let's see other questions.
Oh let's see, so Debbie Charlton
from Facebook is asking,
is Camp Khan any age level
or just 12 years and above.
- Camp, Khan I believe
is at any age level,
it's gonna be built around
the get ready courses,
which started at get
ready for third grade.
So yeah, they should, it should work
for anybody getting ready
for next school year in math.
- Yeah, let's see there's another course
and I actually think it's
a lot of the mechanics
are actually the motivation mechanics.
It's really, I think especially
fun for younger students.
You know I would say, ages
eight to I would say 13,
14 are probably the students
who are going to get the most
out of like all of the fun of Camp Khan.
I would like to believe
that also 14 or 15 year olds
or 16 year olds would also like enjoy it.
But I would also like to believe
that they don't need
all the fun motivation,
because they are determined young adults
to master the skills they need.
So there's one last
question I see here about,
do we have a course in
a differential equation?
I'll say, I'll just
say we do have a course
in differential equations.
That's from Keshav Badari,
it does not have the
our differential equations
course right now is just videos.
It does not have all of
the interactive exercises,
and course challenges and mastery
and everything that
Lindsay's been talking about,
but we do have it.
And it's a little bit of an older course.
I remember making it back
in 2000, probably 2010.
But it's there and people still say
that they find it useful.
So hopefully you do as well.
Let's see so, well it looks like
we're actually almost out of time.
Well, Lindsey, what
else does the math team
you know forshadow for us?
What else are, might be
coming down the pipeline?
- Yeah, so the math team,
where we're always you know
working on the existing courses,
improving the content,
thinking of you know
new ways we can innovate to teach things,
different strategies we can use.
One thing that could be coming,
we just heard about
differential equations,
not having a practice content.
Currently there's another
course, multivariable calculus,
another one of our higher level courses
that currently is all articles and videos.
So learning as, sort
of learning components,
but we are adding practice
components to that.
So now the videos we'll have practice
alongside those videos where you can,
you know do the videos
and then check for your understanding
and do the practice problems,
interactive piece as well.
So we are adding that in one
of our college level courses.
So maybe another one soon.
- Yeah, that's very exciting
multivariable calculus.
And I do think this is
maybe there's other resources in there.
I Think this is frankly the only place
where you're gonna be able
to get mastery practice.
You know we already have the videos
in multivariable calculus,
but this is going to give you
as much practice as you need
to understand that you've mastered it.
I'll throw out some other foreshadowing.
You know we have a Lindsay and her Team
have worked on things like learning plans
for the back several months
of last school year in the Summer.
We're definitely looking at,
can we create learning plans,
which are really, you know if you're doing
get ready for grade level
courses or grade level courses,
what are reasonable goals
for a student to be,
you know what units should
they complete by what date
in order to be on pace?
So that's something that
we are contemplating.
If we have the resources to be able to do,
I'll also throw out
and actually, Lindsay probably
doesn't know about this.
I always have my own
little Skunkworks projects.
I will do a plug, so
there's a side project.
It's a Sal project right now.
It's not officially Khan Academy,
but maybe one day it will be,
if it gets off the ground,
we call it, we're calling
it schoolhouse.world.
And the reason why I'm mentioning it is
obviously you can learn on Khan Academy
at your own time and pace
used to get ready for grade level courses,
do the grade level courses.
But many of you are wondering,
well can I get tutoring?
Could, is there a place where someone,
alive person could help me
and schoolhouse.world it's
you could call it an alpha.
It's a very nascent experimental project
where people can sign up and it'll pair
a people who can run
group tutoring sessions
on different topics on Khan Academy
with students who need it.
And they're starting their full,
any of y'all should go
to schoolhouse.world
and there's a little registration form,
and they're kinda letting people in
as we have enough teachers
and we have enough students
and they're focused right now in calculus,
because it seems like over the summer,
there's a lot of students
who need help in calculus,
where I guess we're preparing
for next school year.
And so, especially in calculus,
there's gonna be 22 classes for free
by volunteer teachers, volunteer tutors
in calculus this week.
So go to schoolhouse.world,
if you want that.
And obviously you could
imagine a future where
many people are on schoolhouse.world,
and we're gonna be able
to draw more bridges
between the Khan Academy world and that,
but I'll throw that out as well.
So Lindsay, thanks so much for joining
and I'm very excited for you know
hopefully a lot of people are gonna learn
from the work that you
and the Team have done.
- Thanks so much Sal,
thanks for having me.
- Well thanks everyone for joining.
As you can see you know the art
of management and leadership
is just hiring people
that are smarter than yourself.
And if I were to praise myself,
I think I'm relatively good at that.
So thanks so much for
joining this live stream.
And I look forward to seeing
all of y'all tomorrow.